well this is a pairing that years ago I
would have never saw coming
did you see the Hat right I think we
have five years of a show cut southern
charm to know why Katherine's lineage is
established but just because somebody
came here and had a name 200 years ago
it doesn't mean that you have class or
breathing now did you ever think this
would happen
frankly no that's kind of the beauty of
life is that you can never predict
what's gonna happen but safe to say
you've taken this one under your wing a
little bit yeah we're your friends we're
close friends once sworn enemies now
besties
et met up with Kathryn Dennis and
Patricia Altschul at Pat's home in
Charleston South Carolina for a good
old-fashioned catch up the pair's at
first ever interview together what does
it mean Kathryn to be sitting here next
to Patricia a lot of progress has been
made in my life and I think overall in
my relationships with everyone a lot of
my problems really go back to Thomas
because he was very convincing and
telling me things about Kathryn and we
didn't have any open communication I
think Kathryn has always been this
Kathryn but there were bumps in the road
right always they we finally got to a
point where we kind of like each other
actually it turns out how much time do
you guys spend together now you know it
was a slow progression from the finale
we would have the occasional dinner but
since you've had a boyfriend I haven't
seen quite as much happier right no I've
been kind of off the grid for a little
while you know the honeymoon phase
sometimes that's best but your ex is
still very much in your life Thomas is
not on the new season but he is still a
big part of the new season how do you
feel about all the stuff that's going to
be discussed on the show and
Thomas honestly I think in the most
neutral way possible I'm quite numb to
it you know I'm not nothing surprises me
and it's unfortunate that negative
things happen and are talked about but
it's a part of my life at this point so
I just keep living in my bubble and
moving on moving forward what about you
Pat well as you know I have no problem
giving my opinion on anything whether
anybody asks me or not but I cannot say
anything about Thomas because he served
me with papers I've I'm subpoenaed you
won't get anything from me after
announcing his exit from the series in
the wake of sexual misconduct
allegations brought against him
all of which he's denied Thomas filed a
lawsuit against Bravo in the production
company behind southern charm in part
claiming producers encouraged Kathryn to
fight to change her custody agreement
with him for the sake of drama on the
show it's just big overwhelming his
co-stars have been subpoenaed as part of
the suit but Pat did have this to say
about her former friend we're talking
earlier somebody wrote well Thomas is
not going to be on the show and you know
it's it's gonna be boring I think this
is gonna be the best season
alert can I ask you about a Thomas
related person oh boy
asha with that big who pops up this
season pops up literally I don't know
where how do you feel about Ashley right
now let's just say I'm happy with the
end result of Ashley Jacobs
the truth safe to say right now neither
of you has anything to do or wants
anything to do with Ashley yes say being
charitable hath Ingenix the other that
you were trying to get a restraining
order against her um yes included in my
most recent motion is a restraint
against her being around my children I
think it's best that she's just a
non-existent human and always so are she
and Thomas together right now they are
and they aren't who knows that they're
together and not together they probably
don't know either and it'll probably
always be that way let me tell you what
somebody told me they ran into Thomas
and they said are you still with that
woman and he said well yeah I mean who
else am I gonna get actually he said
those exact words to me at one point too
but think about why would he say that he
wouldn't yeah he wouldn't just say that
for fun it always seems that maybe
Thomas one day wanted to be back with
you do you feel that way it's difficult
to say because I do care for him however
I feel that I I don't know do you think
he would ever change I hope one day
maybe we'll see but I've been hoping for
a long time good or bad you're in each
other's lives yeah exactly
what is the custody situation right now
it's still in progress nothing's been
resolved yet so it's a long process all
right season six if you had to boil the
season down just to one word
how would you describe it one word all
right I don't think I live that's every
season I've been a great you've renewed
scoffs I know you want him to talk here
and check right now sorry I don't think
I'm letting the cat out of the bag but
the guys who have gotten away with
murder are really gonna get taken down a
peg but there's there's gonna be a
reckoning with all of them what are you
most excited for the viewers to get to
experience about this season for me
personally it's that I'm able to be
myself and I'm not attached to anyone
else or referenced as someone's
girlfriend someone's baby mama it's just
me being me in my life and it's I'm
excited that people will just get to see
that side of me you know I'm finally
getting back to myself that might
include a little bit of her old self can
you set the record straight what
happened oh man he's sitting in front of
his mind yeah let me answer in there
Sonny let me answer this for you this is
what Whitney told me he said I love
Katherine we're good friends but a
Southern gentleman would never discuss
what he does with a lady so and a
southern lady does not discuss what she
does with a Southern gentleman nothing
there you're talking about consenting
adults who cares my question is who
cares there you go
well the viewers care a lot um I mean if
it if things were to get serious but
even those how would you feel if she
became your daughter-in-law one day I'd
love it how would you feel I love it